To change path tracer settings, we have a couple of options.
We can adjust the parameters through a post-processing volume,
as well as through CVars.
To start, we're going to drop a post-processing volume in our scene and
break down the common parameters you'll likely change for your project.
So inside the project, I have duplicated our level, and
I've simply just disabled path tracer, and I've disabled the post-processing volume.
So before we turn on path tracer, let's go ahead and
go over to our Place Actors tab and search for a post-processing volume.
I'll drag that into our scene, and I'm gonna make a couple quick changes so
we can see the effect of the post-processing volume.
So in the Details panel, I'm gonna scroll down, and
I'm going to look for infinite extent unbound.
Simply check that, and then we're gonna go back to the top, and
I'm going to look for our exposure and check my Exposure Compensation and
my Min and Max EV.
Now in this case, I just want to clamp it,
although the default results are probably fine.
If you find that the exposure is ramping up and down too much, we can set our Min
and Max EV to something like zero, and then adjust our Exposure Compensation.
And I'm gonna go ahead and just do that now.
So set these to zero, and then our Exposure Compensation,
we can drag it down to something that works.
I will go negative six.
All right, and then to activate our path tracing,
we're gonna go up to our Lit and simply hit Path Tracing.
And you'll see that these samples will start calculating, and
we will see our reflections and refractions and
shadows update as soon as the calculations are done.
So we'll let this run, I'll time lapse this real fast, and then we'll come back.
Perfect, now Path Tracer has calculated the scene from the camera perspective.
Of course, if we move our camera, it is going to recalculate the scene for us.
Let's jump over to our post-processing volume that we just added, and
I'm going to scroll down within the post-processing actor.
Now there are several things that I encourage you to play with.
So for example, bloom, some of like traumatic aberration, lens exposure.
You can even color correct your scene, your shadows, your midtones,
your highlights, whatever you decide.
However, for this particular section, what I wanna cover are some of
the features of path tracing that we can control directly through our
post-processing volume.
So towards the bottom here, we have a path tracing section, and
you'll see that there are several different parameters that we can adjust.
Now to adjust these and override the defaults,
simply check the box and change the values within your little scrubber here.
Of course, you can click and type in whatever you would like, and
these settings will take effect.
Now I wanna take just a quick side step and
talk about balancing our editor performance and our final visual output.
So if we take a look at our scene,
we have our post-processing volume that's included in the startup map.
And you'll notice that under the path tracing settings,
we have various different properties that are checked and
those values are either changed or just set at the default.
The key thing here being that within our editor,
we can have our post-processing volume.
We can set these parameters to something that's lower and more performant.
So our scene updates faster and
we're spending less iteration cycles waiting for the engine to update.
Of course, this is great for real-time performance, but
it's not ideal for our final output, right?
We wanna bump up our settings to 11 and get the very best visuals that we can.
So I'm gonna show you real quick.
So if we go up to Window, Cinematics, Movie Render Queue,
I've just simply loaded a sequence that's included in the project into this.
And then under Settings, I've made a few changes, and
that's what I wanna highlight right now.
So if I just click the Settings here, the key parts that we're going to hit
are the anti-aliasing and console variables.
Obviously, we'll have path tracing enabled because that's what we're working with.
Underneath anti-aliasing, I would highly recommend for spatial and
temporal sample counts, setting those both to 10.
Now, obviously, this is a deeper topic and subject than we're gonna cover in this one.
But by setting both your spatial and temporal sample counts to 10,
you should get a very good output, but also not take forever to render the scene.
And then finally, you'll get a warning if you don't check Override Anti-Aliasing,
because we are now specifying different properties,
different parameters than the defaults.
So we have to check Override Anti-Aliasing.
All right, now on to console variables.
Now, this is a great setting that you can add just by clicking the setting, and
it would be up here in the top section where we say console variables, but
because we've added it, it doesn't show in this list.
And what we have the ability to do in Movie Render Queue is by specifying some
of these console variables, we can overwrite whatever is in our engine
during the export process from Movie Render Queue.
So for example, max bounces or max samples per pixel,
if we really crank those up pretty high, it's gonna take a long time for
our scene to render.
So in Movie Render Queue, I can specify those console variables,
which you can see here, r.pathTracing.samplesPerPixel, I've set it to 2048.
Now I can do the same thing with our max bounces, right?
So r.pathTracing.maxBounces, and bump it up to 64.
I'll show you real quick just how you add a console variable.
So by default, this is rolled up.
We click a little plus, and you'll see that it adds another line.
And I could do something like r.pathTracing, and
let's just say that I want to enable denoiser, and that should be .denoiser.
And if you're unsure what the value is,
you can highlight over the actual console variable, and
it should give you a contextual pop-up.
So in this case, 0 is disabled, 1 is enabled.
So for example, if in my post-processing volume, the denoiser was deactivated,
I can simply set this to 1.
And then now, when I render my movie render queue,
it's going to override those properties of our post-processing volume.
So this is a great way to be able to balance your performance,
which will be your post-processing volume.
So to balance the performance of your editor with bumping up your high visual
qualities without having to go and manually set these each and every time.
So once this is done, you can actually click this little drop down,
save as a preset, accept.
So now, when you load up your sequences for movie render queue,
you can simply select your preset, and you're good to go.
Now one other quick note is the reference atmosphere parameter within
the path tracing rollup within our post-processing volume.
When this property is checked and enabled,
it will allow path tracing within the atmosphere,
instead of baking the sky atmosphere contributions from the skylight.
So any skylight in your scene when this property is checked will be ignored.
Now something to take note of here is that we have available to us
these lighting components.
Now checking the box will allow or
disable the pass when calculated by path tracer.
So for example, if we disabled the indirect specular,
you'll notice now in our scene that all of the indirect specular contributions
are no longer being processed by path tracer.
Of course, if we want to re-enable it, we can check this box or simply uncheck,
and now those indirect specular calculations will be processed.
Now something else to take note of here is while we have these components or
these settings that we can change within our post-processing volume,
there are some advantages to using CVARS.
Some of those primary advantages lie in the ability to isolate and
output the results of each of our paths within Movie Render Queue.
So just keep that in mind.
All right, now something else to keep as a pro tip is when you're using
emissive materials in your scene, it may be necessary to disable this
emissive pass to prevent double lighting calculations.
So again, that's gonna be in our post-processing volume under our path
tracing.
Simply check emissive and then uncheck if you are experiencing some of those
double lighting calculations.
Now in previous versions of Unreal Engine, path tracer did have some issues
with translucency and depth of field.
In 5.6, we remedied most of these problems by enabling the reference depth of field
property within the path tracing settings of our post-processing volumes.
In the next section, we're gonna jump into modifying some of our material
features to work with path tracer.